we are the the buttress force in case
that FEMA or HHS calls upon us to deploy
medical professionals across the country
to meet crises but we plan for that
every day we are gaming out emergency
preparedness scenarios and we we stand
ready when the president needs us to
expand our mission the Department of
Veterans Affairs and its medical
professionals are prepared and activated
in all kinds of emergencies and the
köppen 19 crisis looks like it may yet
be another example of that VA hospitals
are not just reserved for veterans in
these scenarios and they do generally
have extra beds available that can help
if there is a spike in incoming patients
Veterans Affairs Secretary Robert Wilkie
joins us to talk about that and more
about how the department is getting
ready mr. secretary welcome back to Fox
News at night Thank You Shannon thank
you for having me I got to tell you you
know we've talked about I have a family
member who's been in VA care I did not
know that there are times in which you
would take in civilians and handle other
emergencies under your umbrella well the
first emergency mission that we have
Shannon is to prepare to help the
country in times of war in times of
national pandemics like this and so what
we have is something that is similar to
the reserves in the Armed Forces we have
a Reserve Component within the VA family
of about 3,000 doctors nurses engineers
who deploy in times of crisis they are
at the call of the president call of
FEMA in this case and and we go where we
are we are needed in terms of our
facilities our mission is again to help
the country when we have space that is
not being occupied by veterans so we are
we are looking at the number of beds
that we have that are empty we are
constantly examining where our
facilities stand there are some
facilities that are that are very
crowded and there others that aren't but
again our first priority when it comes
to the beds is veterans and then we look
at the needs of the states and
localities and what about issues of
staffing I mean reveal news org has a
piece that says data published by the
agency in February shows the VA is short
44,000
healthcare professionals including 2,700
doctors 11300 nurses and nursing
assistants the VA is beset by quote
large staffing shortages including
physicians and registered nurses
according to a September report from the
GAO please address that with in light of
everything yes well yes well I think the
GAO report is silly first of all we we
submitted the largest budget in the
history of our department last year
calling for 400,000 employees well we
had 393 thousand and we we carried out
the largest number of appointments in
the history of our department 60 million
where we do have shortages is where the
rest of the country has shortages
particularly in mental health and and
subspecialties in areas like cancer and
and primary care so that's that's where
our shortages are but in terms of the
delivery of our services we have never
delivered as much and we have never
delivered as varied services as we have
just in the last few years and I owe a
lot of that to the attention that the
president the United States has given to
veterans I I've said often that no
campaigner in the history of
presidential elections has ever made
veterans the centerpiece of his campaign
and he carried out that promise when he
entered the White House and he's busy
talking with a lot of Governors as they
look at all kinds of options from the
National Guard to getting materials from
DoD caches I want to play something from
Governor John bel Edwards down in
Louisiana and a request that he may make
right
I'm asking for health in terms of
surging on medical capacity here in
Louisiana we've got some requests in for
example we have a VA hospital in New
Orleans we've requested to be able to
serve patients there we haven't received
the response yet so he references a VA
hospital in New Orleans how does that
decision get made does it go through the
administration through you specifically
or someone else well the way the
national emergency works that those
requests have to go through in detailed
form to FEMA and HHS but I had a long
conversation with the governor of
Louisiana today that's the hometown of
my parents New Orleans and our Hospital
in New Orleans has precisely 28 empty
beds now we are preparing those beds for
the influx of veterans in New Orleans
who now have the virus New Orleans is
the largest cache of veterans who have
the virus in the country much higher
than Seattle much higher than New York
so our priority first is our veterans
and then we will reassess to see when
requests come in if we can help the
states and localities the president's
instructions to me with that the first
line of defense is local local
engagement than state management and
federal support so that's the hierarchy
we use yeah and we're gonna talk about
that a little bit later how all those
things work together and prioritize in
the meantime mr. secretary thank you
again for visiting and we just wish you
all the best as you try to ramp up and
be a part of this very important fight
for the u.s. thank you sir well well
thank you Thank You Shannon